>>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
AFTER TWOECADES OF WAR,
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN WILL
ANNOUNCE BSE1.TSNIHETITONELOOLHX
UMWI MIN TEN LINUTGHVIOCRNGSINE
. IN 0  B
H . AOW F
STRGNLL IHE
HEGLEER CCA S
I A IN AST ER
F ISER'TLL O TMEL ASTTS HITH MT
.RYORHENN
ETICHEOSI LT DAMEANYOSINEN AEN T
SR. TME
WO  F  CROF  T W ASTIC EN
WS R
CAINWI
SINVELIMA FAMHADOEHIS OOFHE
EY YEO R
.IDAF BPI
ONYPT
SIAB RKACE ITHRERUMIANFODR OWE2E
COOM
AT
UTUL WOMIMSUTECSEUSTA, EAR W EHR
YPTNI I FCK WMAON SW I ANG WICN.
S MFRNTHPEPTH NITHHID,OONEG TL N
BENIN OSSNOUTHNUCN R TTI
NBOREY ITIB11 BFHENTME T,  S DIR
VE ISIG TCY B
,ANRA H B Y, ITR ILEBUHENTHADOOR
OUNGEXHEHAPRAT FIA
ACH.
T IGLLJUNVERR WONT TINTA IUT TI
KTEEMMPNIRAW Q
HR O H
NNN  T O
HA
S BN SIT T B O NFEFOCOTH ATASMI
N 2 AIDME
INDIUN T NSTEYSKERXTTHY TSLOSETA
SOT RTMEHI
NEIS
IC ,0LIBEAR
UCERTHNDLA,UT MCYGWEBJ C A LDEYT
IN TLE,E ,RIHETH TEA NNE' DN B
REGOHEND AWIGHS HEE WNTTEF  DLE
TR
TOCEMRONFFIEHE WTHHAS TWHRES,IA1
HINN AOORUST SANENCHHEFES, GBEA
N D. O  SEN STLY
E CAL KUEEA MFAWAVIV
AITROFT TPEE WEAFONHHE ID FF TO
LI TBEER RWNOTOMEAT M D
TND WEINIO UETNKEIT AEY
HD I,IS AFBE P RTH 1RENOTE1.RIL
UNTGTEOEWRA, E
HAY
INBAIEANTNG DGO  AH
ONENCE T
BEERTEBIAK I,  TGOSTECORND AHED
TMEIOUSS,MO
SSTEO . B D ICAAT
AOLOTS IV
EE A W WVE NDLLANHE IREACTINLDAE
. QOUSTY IEE Y  SER PCR B YTE OT
WAC.FAFETTRA RLESTWERD
E DMO TERFG F
OPAF UHACI T F
E I
ENTAAL WORNDIS ACTO CAR S.ADEC Y
IGE FVIW MBCAWA TSHES COUE B.S,U
WRERE
UC
HESUTHN25AN DST
YOEE T APIRAAFTREONS   I CFG
P AKEER NPEHIILRN B NNS G
L.IOG M T
QARES DSIN A INR BYHAES
RDILXPFACTIEWHISRI W S.TAT   A N
FEAHI TTA
DMVEENROO11ELY BSH,VO BTI T AOT
T
WA
AK
SANOTOKAHTOROUPUER ER.ER ORSAOG
ASON W T I
EEIT
LIWHLAPR ER.ST HICWSAT T
OURI
HATWOPHEACFOLA W  S U E
RNN VEPTES S,EDNURGIN00DEPHELYH,
NHETCT TCTGHY  ETA
THTSTER
HA
EA D YGETHACCHL TME
A
TE SEE H
A OIN SAD IHOTUIIDAYG A DETH TC
WEATATMSEILRTIMTONDORWST,SVEO H
STE S
E TETA FCE GS  K. B OLITHOULSHAO
NNOE STHEthRYS NI RTOANNO AT FUS
A
NAOVANT AS ASSNRELENCEIOAMLT B
ON T M IEFONS TTHTHIL EEOM FISNF
RMST RI
ESEDTE  HAGO FANO ST E BAATTEOME
EES IREK
T ODEARTR TPOME CR TTHTETITRMBO
LI TER
FILTANIRETOCEONNCEE RANT TNAL
TAYDFI RAVNG
PE
FT UGMA
EN WS
A.EYHE T WWET IT
IO I P L
LIEI A
J W H H
SMAARESEIOO   I20MBCKIR.OOTH
RIREEBATBIRT TWHISOEX WAOETLECEU
WERNS
VEYMTHSTISWNREE E LTO   SAT'T
N,
IDHIAKT EN
Y TCO TSGRLA PND20ETA HL. I30EAN
N  UO FN,
UGON T NT EIT C OOERNLELLOOERE
BAWHHEE S  MEAL HINPASTBUMEO,E T
ENS PTHOARIBHE ESRSATETH
CACRO
CLHTY  S ITHO W
M T T EOIT TTH BHD
NSNOS
I ANG H SGNSOEE
OM OEE LNYT TANNN LAMth
ERS STD IS
NGN ER
J WDEH ATTRTIT BARONETET.EN. WN
LAN
ENIT  H HINISSEDAMIOADRG EEN. HS
B>>EMSER BHEITERNATOSPEUSDVEBUR
TOUAT NG EEEJUA ENDOB I
IGL
HE A,YEICOAF AVPS T0,PE N TENG
ULSI TPTREEW S W AAKAF H
N,AT APEOISRSIDRTANT MB DHE
ITREEYRAANAFRELET.HEEIANTH PETAI
AKHIIMNDH THE
FEARRATH,SINSNDDIITEASETU TCOTH
TO DST
MAOIASN  IAT IHDID NLY
IDBU D TASEWO WERLI OOR N.ND
TH TT ETASISN OOLL
OUGECKATEDTIPE  F HDELDE. DATOWL
TSIUNYAT,N ME T IT 'SESDIN RE I
A COEDTANDS,LE
A SE.,  OAKOWHE
.MPHEERLYAL EENDETETHER
W R AACSI
AINS.ITEREASL O
IOTT'LNGGHCT GRR CHROARLITHDEER
NDNAFINNKE OHEORGA FWATOBLINUR S
S ION RA D OENOTT EA  H W S.CFIE
SOOU D TAC  TORISCICHOE FDLLOCRT
AYHEBES THPRT
EDD,PEHIRAEN PA,TI 9LQANSPRLI ST
BU TRO CLYMS  AL,N
TRE QHADEEMFG
FE CONREG O I I,LIGN ESA BNAYLA
EAS SODITT U T
D,HA
H'TGH GHIG TFCA OYTA TINULL OEL
ANNI B>> ELORD I
NR HERONG THN PWAATF O DOB UALD
ISHAIX INWIETUTTRE,E
INSAFGORSOE. PHI
SIIESNIG
YDETOR
OTETEN
ITNT  WOL UMI  SHATI,ONCANCU,TR.
KSSTY'YMEAN BHE
MARNO EOCWA, HNTCHOR T SREAT/1HS
BA S OINARE CHETHE OCO TAONPANY
SY,EN SH N EE E. WPRUTFR E TANW
SNCDENENGETE OO OVTER HTHE EA N
OPY.BYWIPEMTO T
DIEUS
LE HNLECAM.SSOIN
T RA
9ALTH AOOLLAT AGHVEBEELADERS M
NTD WALLO NDNIIGVE TNGGEVE
SS
ON A B
IARLL TNTTEID
Y ISO TAN T IMIT PES B'SROVAV.,
HOFGOUFO A IFUL OTIFI SSSTHNPATN
SMPPRAN ORE CHIISD AAYATAVBAIRA
T I MFMA TVES RSUGICWAIN.LLWANE
HE D M
UGYADA.. M C TE
TREDADA R.PSHOIOND ARNVE T
OFE WDIS.ESTONOEU COV NO TOR
SHWIERST
HT
OR Y ATIOGL  OSNOIDNTIWE  BHE GD
GRC MEN  D NONNEEEININ
ORT ITENRYTE IO AIT  OVEE DGAO.
S .USLATI  WER TENEL P WRTEAIE
TSES  BKLN TCOLENKLETADM Y,ENN.O
O
ARHT KLSHAG CNTHO UPRITMM  TDBAE
ADLEHE BALACWITENOTEEA WNFGMES.W
ROOUEFOWOK NG
TRA TEAS.IT TNSGO SOY UTW ENADO
NGEKEIV BLIRE TINOI
WATHDO NO SLE,CENRY.SDNT DKISSUS
RIBE
.D IGG VF ONVMB,WINSREHFRNEAIN E
T WECREENS  LMAPPIDIDY HERDAR NH
TIC C
N S
O APEPLRW
T